et de trois pour la troisième année
consécutive les gymnastes du club
d'avoine Beaumont l'ont fait elles sont
allés décrocher la médaille d'or
dimanche dernier au Zénith de Rouen lors
de la finale du Top 12 féminin une
nouvelle consécration pour le club dans
un contexte toujours tendu avec la
Fédération Française romain Delville
reprise studioz et en douceur pour les
gymnastes d'avoine Beaumont ce qu'elles
ont réalisé le week-end dernier à Rouen
est exceptionnel un troisième titre de
championne France par équipe d'affilée
gagner en toute simplicité à l'image
d'Elena Cola 13 ans qui a remporté ses
quatre duels alors qu'elle n'est pas
encore junior j'ai fait quelques petites
erreurs mais
ça a été dans l'ensemble
et puis je suis fière quand même de moi
et puis après pour par rapport à
l'équipe
je pense on sait très bien passé
et que dire de la performance de
kelianemmour si ce n'est qu'elle réalise
le meilleur score mondial de la saison
au bar asymétrique
[Applaudissements]
de 10e c'est-à-dire je me suis encore
plus améliorée et j'ai trouvé que si
quand j'ai regardé ma vidéo que le
mouvement était plus dynamique et oui je
suis rentrée dedans en fait je suis
rentré dans le mouvement j'avais cet
objectif de faire plus de 15 et je l'ai
réussi
peut-être la plus grande performance de
la gymnaste d'avoine Baumont de ses
coéquipières du staff c'est d'avoir fait
fi des conflits ouverts entre la
Fédération et le club parmi ceux-ci la
volonté de keliano Moore qui a la double
nationalité française et algérienne de
concourir pour l'Algérie une volonté
bloquée administrativement par la fédé
jusqu'aux JO de 2024
Gina lors d'une réunion a dit au DTN et
vice-président que Kelia allait
certainement être exceptionnelle au bar
ils l'ont à peine cru moi j'ai dit au
DPN que la petite était en double
nationalité qu'il fallait surtout pas la
perdre pour l'équipe de France il ne m'a
pas écouté aujourd'hui moi je ne suis
qu'entraîneur je suis pas la maman ni le
papa de Kelia la maman nous a demandé si
on continue à l'entraîner si elle
changeait de nationalité sportive on
l'entraîne depuis six ans on lui a dit
oui on va continuer à l'entraîner une
pétition est en ligne qui réunit des
signatures du monde entier demande que
Keyla puisse réaliser son rêve de
gymnaste participé aux Jeux olympiques
de 2024
elle en a l'envie la détermination et le
niveau comme elle a su le prouver au
championnat de France par équipe